but rally games will say that because
she's not afraid so last night Gaines
went to San Francisco State University
to talk about her experiences in NCAA
swimming and relegates is not a hater
she is a measured decent person who
believes in logic and reason and finding
common ground with people who disagree
with her
she does not think she is God
but that fact does not believe she's
makes her a terrifying threat to the
zealots who do do their God
and so at San Francisco State last night
the zealous attacked her a mob
surrounded Riley Gaines and prevented
her from moving through the hallways at
one point the thug said they wouldn't
let her pass unless she
during the chaos a man dressed as a
woman punched her several times the mob
howled with rage screaming threats and
obscenities we're not overstating here's
what it looked like
[Music]
this way
thank you
I'm coming I'm good I'm good trust me
I'm good
all right
here
[Music]
that's the most dangerous extremist
group in the United States there's no
mistaking it Riley Gaines once again is
not an ideologue or a demagogue she's
not out to hurt anybody she's a college
swimmer who was cheated against and
doesn't think that's fair
in the face of that people threaten her
life and scream transparently
nonsensical things like trans women or
women trans women are not women women
are men are women and men are men
and that's unalterable and if you think
otherwise you were delusional and they
are delusional and therefore dangerous
last night Riley Gaines was silenced and
assaulted at San Francisco State her
most basic civil rights were stolen by a
violent mob
the thing was supposed to be on the
lookout for well there it is
if there is such a thing as a hate crime
you just saw it
and it's thoroughly corrupt Department
of Justice won't acknowledge that any of
that happened because they endorse it
happening rally Gaines is one of the
bravest people we know and we're
grateful to have her join us tonight
rile against thank you so much for
coming on was that as horrifying as it
looked
I mean it was tariff tearing for me
um the police did not inform me of any
sort of action plan Turning Point USA
invited me to the campus I delivered a
very civil and respectful speech where I
had great dialogue with even protesters
who were participating in a sit-in all
of a sudden after my speech the room was
stormed the lights were turned off and I
was rushed with no one there to escort
me to a safe place I was punched I was
hit multiple times I was shoved until
finally we exited the room but we could
not leave because the protesters flooded
the halls and so I was pushed into a
classroom along that hallway where I was
barricaded in for three hours
three hours why didn't someone with a
gun come and bring you to safety
because they were terrified they were
scared to put their hands on these
people because they know what these
people are capable of these people
yelled obscene violent vulgar things to
both myself and the officers and the
officers I could tell didn't feel
comfortable putting them in a position
that would mean they do their job which
is a really scary chilling thought
this is the most dangerous extremist
movement in the United States right now
it's getting bigger not smaller it's
gaining Steam not losing it the White
House has endorsed it I mean what does
this mean for you and I just can't say
it again since I happen to know you you
are an inherently moderate person who
means harm to no one but are you worried
about your safety going forward
you know I am worried about my safety I
have to be now when we have people who
are willing to do this and we know why
they're willing to do this it's because
they don't have reason they don't have
logic they don't have science they don't
have common sense on their side that's
on my side and so they they protrude by
violence whether it's physical or verbal
violence but what this means for me this
does not deter me this assures me that
I'm doing the right thing this will not
silence me when they want me to be
silenced it just means I need to speak
louder
really quick because any did anyone in
the state of California in Authority any
political figure for example defend you
not the dean of students not the campus
police I will say the city of San
Francisco police that stepped in they
did a phenomenal job in escorting three
hours later but I will be pursuing legal
action I will ensure that the people who
physically assaulted me the people who
put me in that position they will face
repercussions yeah I mean if we can't
identify that as evil then we've really
lost lost the threat rally games I'm
glad you're still here and absolutely
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight